Das ist absolut frappierend.
Die singenden Braunmäuse sprechen miteinander.
Das ist das Ergebnis einer Studie.
Das Forschungsteam hat sich sehr genau angesehen,
was passiert, wenn diese Mäuse miteinander
chirpen.
Und tatsächlich ist das eine menschlichen
Unterhaltung sehr ähnlich.
Und das bedeutet, dass die Wurzeln unserer
Sprache schon sehr früh angelegt wurden.
Wie früh und was das für die Forschung bedeutet
klären wir jetzt bei Clixoom Schince & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, aktiviert die Glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s mit dem Geheimnis der singenden
Mäuse.
Herzlich willkommen!
Heute mit Marius angeschrien, der sich näher
mit den Phänomen der Sprache beschäftigt.
Marius: Manchmal, wenn man so in einem Café
oder auf der Straße das Gebrabbel höre,
denke ich: Hey, hier geht es doch gar nicht
um den Austausch von Informationen, sondern
viel mehr um soziale Botschaften wie: Mag’
ich dich?
Magst du mich?
Finden wir einen gemeinsamen Nenner?
Oder ist das eher eine Konfrontation, ein
Wettkampf?
Gespräche können so vieles sein.
Erst letztlich hat mich eine Freundin gebeten
mit jemand zu telefonieren, weil es bei ihr
immer in den Gesprächen krachte.
Sie konnte mit ihm einfach nicht.
Ich habe es also gemacht und alles war prima.
Also irgendetwas ist da in der Kommunktaion,
was wohl aus unseren uralten Instinkten kommt
und zentraler Bestandteil der gesprochenen
Sprache ist.
Bei Ziegen hat man das ja jetzt festgestellt.
Über die Laute können Ziegen gegenseitig
ihre Emotionen erkennen.
Und genau diese Urform der Kommunikation hat
ein Forschungsteam bei den singenden Braunmäusen
untersucht.
Was passiert in ihrem Gehirn, wenn sie miteinander
singen.
Denn genau das passiert bei den Braunmäusen.
Es ist ein regelrechter Dialog.
Die eine Maus zript, hört auf, die andere
Maus zirpt, wie bei uns Menschen lassen sie
sich (meistens) ausreden und antworten regelrecht.
Bisher war das nur bei Primaten, bei Affen
so festgestellt worden.
Aber diese Mäuse können das auch.
Für die Studie legte das Forschungsteam den
Bereich im Gehirn der Mäuse lahm, der auch
für die mündloiche Sprache benötigt wird,
den Motorcortex Die Mäuse hörten auf zu
kommunizieren.
Der Schluß: Beim Menschen, wie bei den Braunmäusen
ist der gleiche Hirnbereich für die mündliche
Sprache verantwortlich.
Und das bedeutet laut dem an der Studie beteiligten
Neurobiologen Steffen Hage eine extrem spannende
Annahme: Demnach müsste es einen gemeinsamen
Vorfahren von Mäusen und Mensch geben, der
diese Fähigkeit schon hatte.
Und das bedeutet, das das Fundament der Sprache
schon vor 100 Millionen Jahren gelegt wurde.
Christoph: Hammer!
Und es gibt noch mehr von Marius.
Wer hat die Sprache erfunden?
Auch beim Menschen muss sich Sprache am Anfang
sehr seltsam angehört haben.
Mehr dazu erfahrt ihr in diesem Video: Anklicken,
anschauen und auf jeden Fall den Wissenskanal
von Marius angeschrien abonnieren.
Vielen Dank Marius, dass du hier dabei warst!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!